candle wax yeah that's done but he
wouldn't be screaming his head off like
that doesn't hurt that bad hi my name is
Mr stamiana chi I have been a
professional dominatrix in Los Angeles
for over two decades I have a PhD in
Clinical Psychology and I am a certified
sexologist today we're going to be
looking at dominatrix scenes in movies
and TV and judge how real they are
let me see your point Piggy
all these guys that are acting like
clowns so not authentic a true
submissive would go into something
called Subspace
which is a switch in the mindset where
they're feeling submissive and I can see
it easily in Subs they've got an
energetic shift or like a certain look
in their eye in that scene the
submissives were obviously not feeling
submissive they were making fun of
themselves it's kind of been done over
and over and over to use BDSM for shock
value comedic value it's getting old in
my opinion
my dream in life is to bankrupt you she
says my fantasies to bankrupt you it's
real it is not what I believe true BDSM
is financial domination has kind of
exploded unfortunately on the internet
most Financial domination that is done
out there is unethical because they are
done by girls like this who have zero
training and domination BDSM is not
about taking advantage of people it's
about true connection it's about trust
it's about mutual respect
looking at someone's Social Media
account is not a good way to vet someone
I have a vetting process where I ask for
references from the client's previous
Doms but if he doesn't have any
references I ask for a fee for a phone
interview going back and forth on DMs
like this you're just giving them free
time
as a Dom if you feel in any way pushed
into doing something for the money don't
do it it happens a lot to younger Doms
and younger Doms who are untrained this
character is in high school and I don't
admit anyone into my dominatrix Academy
that's under 21. I would rate this an 8
out of 10. it's true to what's happening
right now in society it's not true to
the art form of BDSM did you kidnap this
man and steal his house what do you take
me for he invited us everything so far
really authentic the fantasy is that the
submissive is suffering in his own house
while the ladies are just having a great
time at his expense what he's wearing
too he's wearing headphones and a
blindfold he's got like a latex body
suit on and the cage as well he can't
stretch out it's a short cage that's
pretty authentic as well to go to the
bathroom in this thing we deprive him of
food all weekend long so no worries
about number two otherwise he just goes
when he has to oh still authentic the
way that the Dom is acting is is great
she's really aloof if you want to be a
super cruel you know Dom you can do it
this way where she's being like oh he
can just go when he wants to there's
other ways that I've done I've had
myself wear a diaper I've done it where
I'll administer a catheter and that is
my favorite way because I'm controlling
everything feeling dehydrated Joe
lightheaded no I'm feeling amazing this
is where the authenticity starts falling
Adam would say you're probably getting a
little dehydrated by now but guess what
I will hydrate you when I feel like
hydrating you in the back of her mind
she has a plan she's keeping him safe
but she's not spelling it out for him
and so now the scene is turned to like
top bottom Dynamic rather than a Dom sub
Dynamic she's acting like we call a
service
there's not that control thing happening
and cover me up again how long before we
should come back tomorrow there he is
giving orders to the Dom cover me up
again and check on me tomorrow he's not
being a submissive that's not very fun
the fun part about being a submissive is
you don't know when stuff is going to
happen to you with this scene he's not
real restricted in his movement I
wouldn't leave someone like that not
longer than like two three hours if I
leave I'll have somebody that's
assisting me to to watch over them
sometimes I'll have a camera I rate this
a 7 out of 10. they lost some points
there at the end oh Jesus
oh wow love her outfit she's beautiful
and she looks very Dom like I like you
like it they obviously wanted to make a
comedic scene here out of it here he is
lying there and his legs are flailing
and he's just moving all over the place
a sub that flails like that should have
been put in bondage
candle wax yeah that's done she's doing
it on his back which that's a safe place
to do candle wax but he wouldn't be
screaming his head off like that he
might be screaming if she's using a
candle that isn't safe to play in BDSM
scenes I don't have Subs that scream
their heads off because I use low
burning wax doesn't hurt that bad yes
about your safe word it is unsafe for
Adam to say that and do that and ignore
the the subs calling out his safe word
what if that candle is one of those High
burning candles that is scorching his
skin and it might actually be burning
him way more than she thinks it is in
that case the sub has to just get up and
walk out the door as best as he can I
would rate this a 3 out of ten at her
saying I don't give a [__] about your
safe word
that kind of blew it there the following
are the terms of a binding contract
between the dominant and the submissive
authentic this sort of contract is done
between partners in a lifestyle DS
relationship versus a professional
relationship somebody like me the safe
word yellow will be used to bring to the
attention of the dominant that the
submissive is close to her limit this is
very well written very thorough those
are the most common safe words used in
the BDSM scene in general sometimes the
safe words are not verbals let's say I
have someone in bondage and he's gagged
and he can't speak then I'll give him a
little hand signal I'll say like pound
the table three times the submissive
will eat regularly to maintain our
health and well-being the submissive
will not drink to excess smoke I liked
how he put things in there about her
self-care when the Dom is controlling
every aspect of her life she feels very
very cared for it's very much like that
Dynamic of the parent child all of the
Parts where he's explaining to her what
she's allowed to eat it's seen as a
positive it's not seen as a negative at
all I would rate this a 10 out of 10.
all those implements very authentic in
fact one of the floggers that was
hanging there looks just like the one
that I have here look at all the trouble
you've caused leave with me or
administer the required Corrections
ah love it first of all all the dungeon
equipment that I've seen here is made
for a real BDSM dungeon the double Doms
that happens a lot the having a dialogue
mistress and mistress talking about him
like he's just a third party who's not
even there
why aren't you showing the proper
appreciation I should put you in this
cage this is what I've been waiting for
to see something like this you know how
you feel the drama there's a lot of
drama in a real BDSM scene it's serious
it could feel scary and explore what
other fantasies then what fantasies
exactly you being with other men he's
asking her if she fantasizes about being
with other men that is very real the
fantasy of being cuckolded is very
common the cuckolding fantasy is where
the dominant mistress has sexual
relations with another person and it's a
turn on because
it hurts his feelings you want to be
funny
it lost excruciating
you're somewhere private a hotel a hotel
oh God I have chills running up the back
of my head he said that's the most
excruciating thing that I can think of
so to him that's more painful than any
physical pain that she could administer
finally he's being serious he's he's
going through all the emotions that a
submissive would and then she said
something like is it in a hotel you know
so she's fantasizing with him now so
she's making him visualize it very very
real it's very hot very good easy 10 out
of 10. everything about it was excellent
I noticed this immediately the flogging
technique is is not right the flogger
just wrapped around his shoulder
wrapping is bad technique because you
can't control how hard you're hitting so
what she should do is stand a little bit
back so that it doesn't wrap over his
shoulder like that
so at the beginning it showed him smile
a little bit right that's so fake he
might get into a euphoric State later on
but not the first minute he'd be wincing
foreign
cares for the submissive physically
emotionally because you're coming down
from a really really heavy scene so
tending to his wounds is a good part of
Aftercare if the submissive needs it and
also she was having conversation with
him like during Aftercare what I do with
my Subs is I bond with them sometimes on
topics outside of the scene I thought it
was really really good that they
included the Aftercare in the show
because that part's not seen a lot so
I'm going to rate this a 4 out of 10.
laughs
oh such a great start what she's doing
is called trampling she's not using her
full weight of her heels which that's
dangerous you shouldn't do that but
she's doing it right stop moving
sorry mistress I shall have to punish
you the stop moving I shall have to
punish you typical dominatrix line
reading the magazine too is great
because that's kind of like you know I'm
just doing my normal thing while you're
down there suffering and he's calling
her mistress so finally we see that
please stop okay get up if you want
no no don't ruin it that's not what a
mistress would say when he said stop in
the scene that was a part of him wanting
to be helpless and resistant and he
wanted to prompt her to role play back
to him who's trying to say no I don't
want to get up so that kind of showed
her naivete if it's the storyline of the
episode her being a new mistress how do
you know if you're doing it right in my
job if you make a man come that's
success with this I can't even tell if
he's enjoying it there are other ways to
figure out if a sub is enjoying things
or not if it's a stone cold look on his
face he stopped breathing to me these
are red lights I would time out and say
okay
what's wrong just a minute oh you
disgust me I've run out of ideas and
I've still got Asians to go
that's natural new Dom is going to run
out of ideas and she's going to
maybe not ask in the middle of a session
advice from someone but look on her face
and you disgust me
great it's showing that she's still got
a handle on her mistress role and then
do the kids kitchen
the guy look in the toilet realistic
actually I've done that it's not super
common if I ever made someone do that I
would make sure that the toilet is not
like filthy
I would rate this a 9 out of ten it was
very realistic now help me with this
tarp you're peeing on Fred
yeah assistance happen when the Dom
doesn't want to do a particular thing
sometimes the client will want someone
that's more vanilla than me that isn't a
Dominatrix and maybe another part of a
special Kink is having this boy do it
instead of the dominatrix I wouldn't
call someone who acted like this person
who was hesitant about it it would ruin
the scene I told my friends how funny
you were
okay no clients don't tell their friends
this is a secret private thing sometimes
if they're in the community then they'll
tell those friends in the community
[Applause]
no I don't wear raincoats when I pee on
someone that must be part of the set
designer's idea because they have a
plastic tarp under him and they want it
to match that's all for looks for for TV
where do you want it Freddy okay stop
the where do you want it they're acting
like
he's getting his hair done it's not like
that how a BDSM scene works is that you
have the pre-seen talk
where you might have negotiations and
then once you get into the scene you
don't really ask those types of
questions anymore I would rate this a
one out of ten I was thinking
that you do something a little different
today everything here it looks very
realistic like it's actually in
somebody's like private dungeon like a
room in their house or something like
that I play your part you play my part
sure we'll have to do a quick contract
it's your safe word red that can happen
this feels like a top bottom scene to me
there's not a lot of formality to it
like okay let's not do that let's do
this in the middle of it she wanted to
switch so they threw in a bunch of BDSM
terminology there we should do a quick
contract my safe word is red it seems
like a real lifestyle scene to me you
know what I should do
beat the [__] out of you that's what I
should do I should
[Applause]
super intense she's taking out something
else
on this person you should never bring
anger into a scene either about the sub
or about anything when there's real
anger involved you should not be doing
any BDSM at all so that was really
intense for me to watch and I'm glad you
called red and hopefully she did stop
because this kind of thing happens I
would rate this a 10 out of 10 because
this seemed like a very real lifestyle
scene to me gone wrong my favorite TV
show featuring a dominatrix is billions
inspired by the clip that I saw here
because it was the most realistic
domination that I had seen thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video why
not click the video above